how do you learn the basics of business
I got a question today from Jonathan who
wrote exactly that he's a YouTube
follower and he's struggling right now
he doesn't know if he should keep good
in his education everybody tells me to
go get a degree but he wants to start a
business and he's not sure about
anything abyss he doesn't know what
business he wants to start he has no
business background he's just excited by
it and doesn't want to lose the
opportunity so great question Jonathan
and I feel for you I remember being in
university so I went University I got my
degree but at the same time I wanted to
start my own business and I actually
started it when I was in university I
met up with two people who are also at
the same University and we built this
software company together and I remember
when I graduated most of my friends went
off to get jobs at these big companies
and I had opportunity to do it too and I
thought I'm gonna regret this for the
rest of my life if I don't take the time
now to try it because when you're young
you don't have the attachments right you
don't have the commitments you don't
have as many responsibilities I didn't
have a wife you didn't have kids I
didn't have anything or anyone to look
after except myself and so I thought
this is the time to try and do it
because I do not want to live the rest
of my life regretting and so I told
myself I'm going to take one year off I
graduated I'm going to take one year off
and try to do this business thing and if
it doesn't work out those same job
opportunities will still be there for me
I never went back to get a job doesn't
may not be your story but that's mine
what I would encourage you to do to
learn the basics is start now and if
you're not sure what you want to do
start on both paths start getting a
degree and try to incorporate your
business into it as much as possible
when I was in university I tried to use
my business that I was starting as a
case study for every course that I was
doing if I had a marketing project I
always applied it to my business I used
it as an example if I had a advertising
exercising and to do I applied it to my
business
in my last year I managed to convince
one of my professors to do a self-guided
course and instead of actually going on
doing a course he worked with me on my
business and a Canada is a credit so I
always use my business in conjunction
with my education I think it's really
hard to to teach entrepreneurship in
universities I think it's possible I
don't think a lot of universities do a
good job mine certainly did not because
so much of it is hands-on you've got to
get into it and so what I've encouraged
you to do is start looking at
opportunities to do your business and do
your education until you get confident
comfortable enough to go out and branch
on your own until you get with certainty
that decision that this is what I need
to do right now another great way to
learn the basics is start working for a
company who you respect admire look up
to want to be a part of so say you're
interested in graphic design and you one
day want to start your own graphic
design business go find a job at a small
graphic design shop don't go work for
the biggest guy in the industry because
that's not what your short term plan is
going to be if you're going to start a
business go learn from somebody who's a
few steps ahead of you work for somebody
who has maybe ten employees and learn as
much about the business as possible
don't just do what they hire you to do
do as much as you can to get close to
the founder the entrepreneur founder
learn from them learn the projects get
involved in as many areas of the
business as possible because they will
teach you how to do their job how they
started their business you learn the ins
and outs of running that kind of company
and you'll learn one is this something
you want to do you know may sound great
on paper but once you get into it you
may think oh but this is crazy this is
this isn't what I thought it was at all
I'm so glad I didn't just spend my life
saving and starting this company because
it's not for me so it gives you
certainty but it also teaches you the
skills gives you connections and trains
you and how to be a
cessful entrepreneur in that field and
that can be a part-time job - you could
pursue your education and do this thing
part-time to learn the ropes so you're
getting paid to learn your university
you're paying to learn here you're
getting paid to learn and make mistakes
you're getting paid to make mistakes and
then when you're ready to go do your own
thing you have the experience you're not
going to make as many mistakes you have
contact Selena and you'll know if
starting the business is for you or not
so that's my best advice for you at the
end of the day you have to do what's
right in your heart you may be fine with
going out and becoming a corporate
worker right that's fine that that's for
some people but if you have this burning
desire here in your heart that you need
to do this you want to be an
entrepreneur then you owe it to yourself
to at least dry you don't want to look
back on your life and regret that you
didn't do this and a quick story from
Jeff Bezos one of my favorite
entrepreneurs from amazon.com he was 40
years old he was a vice president at a
successful company the youngest ever VP
at his company making huge dollars and
he left it all to start a company called
amazon.com and everybody thought he was
crazy you're gonna sell books over the
internet what who's gonna buy that
that's ridiculous and this was the early
early early days of the internet now it
seems like a no-brainer but for that
time it was a huge risk he left
everything he knew all the security the
high paying job to start this business
and the reason why he did it
is he didn't want to live with the
regret of not trying he knew that would
haunt him for the rest of his life so at
the end the day you have to do what's
best for you what's in your heart and if
you want to learn the basics start by
doing a part-time start with running
your own company part-time or going to
work for another company who's doing
exactly what you want to do and model
their success belief for those watching
thumbs up below thank you guys so much
and makes you want to do more videos for
you and leave a comment let me know what
you think you have a problem with your
business you have a question leave it
below and I'll make a video
phonce just like this thank you so much
I'll see you soon